Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München zur Verfügung gestellt. Jetzt schalte ich auf Englisch um und
habe das Vergnügen und die Ehre
, Ihnen unser Panel vorzustellen. Unser
Markenname ist Professor an der University of
Pittsburgh. Er erwarb seinen BA an der Yale
University und seinen PhD an der Princeton
Im Jahr 1994 veröffentlichte er an der Universität sein
berühmtes Buch, das es explizit machte, gefolgt
im Jahr 2000 von einer Art kürzerer Version, in der
die Gründe artikuliert wurden
2006 Non-Locke-Vorlesungen an
der Universität Oxford, und sie wurden
veröffentlicht
zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Matrosen-
Empirismus und Philosophie des Geistes ist
die frühere Form eine Form von Empi  ricismus
entwickelte sich aus der Arbeit von Russell und
Karna. Die spätere Form ist, wie Rory es ausdrückt
, eine postpositivistische Form
der analytischen Philosophie. Für Rorty ist der
Wechsel von der früheren zur späteren
Form mit den Verbrechenswerken des
späteren Wittgenstein verbunden und verkauft den
General  Idee dieser Verschiebung von der
früheren zur späteren Form ist eine Kritik
an der Mitte des Gegebenen, um einen
berühmten Ausdruck des Dienens zu zitieren. Was bedeutet
dieser Ausdruck gut
? Diese Theorie der Philosophie ist zutiefst
beeinflusst von der Kluft zwischen Welt und
Geist  die realen Dinge und
die nicht so reale Welt Wörter, die sich
irgendwie auf die Realität beziehen, was auch immer die Welt ist,
es ist gegeben, was auch immer die Dinge sind,
sie sind gegeben, andererseits sind unsere
Gedanken und Worte nicht gegeben, und
dies scheint ein Nachteil für unsere
Gedanken und Worte zu sein  Weil es die
Welt ist, die unsere Gedanken wahr oder
falsch macht, sind
die Dinge der Welt die
Wahrheitsstifter, aber sie sind für sich selbst nicht
wahr, aber angesichts der Lücke dazwischen  Welt und
Geist ist der Arbeitsplatz für zahlreiche
Brückenbauer, die die Kluft überbrücken wollen,
um wahres
Wissen über die Welt zu erlangen, aber am Ende
entdecken sie, dass es keine mögliche
Brücke zwischen der Welt und dem Geist gibt,
weil die Kluft ist  zu tief
beide seiten sind zu unterschiedlich
er nennt dies eine folge einer gewissen angst vor
der wahrheit
wir scheitern daran, eine brücke zwischen
welt und verstand zu schlagen, weil wir scheitern wollen
und der beste weg, das
scheitern aller versuche zu garantieren, ist der mythus
der Givens
Sobald die Kluft zwischen einer bestimmten Welt und einem
völlig anderen Geist festgestellt
ist, ist die Wahrheit unmöglich und Skepsis die
einzige Option, die er legal hat, ist ganz
klar, dass
man sich dem Mythos des gegebenen Robert Branham widersetzen muss, um den Skeptizismus abzuschaffen,
wie ich es verstehe in der
Tradition  dieser späteren Form der analytischen
Philosophie vor allem in der Pittsburgh-
Tradition von Sara widersetzt sich daher
der Kluft zwischen Welt und Geist und
behauptet, sie zitiere nicht nur scheinbar  Da
aber auch die Realität konzeptionell
artikuliert
wurde, hieß diese Behauptung früher Idealismus, denn ihr Idealismus
war wahr, weil es die einzige Möglichkeit war,
Realismus zu verteidigen, ist Idealismus die Wahrheit.
Realismus. Ich denke, das ist genau die
Frage, und wenn ich mich nicht irre  das ist auch
die frage von robert brendham
wir werden gleich mehr darüber erfahren
hat hambrick aufgegeben beteiligt
hegel beginnt den ersten absatz der
einführung der phänomenologie des
geistes mit der einführung eines modells der
kognitiven fähigkeiten, von denen er annimmt
, dass sie am vertrautesten sein werden  seinen Lesern in
seiner inhaltlichen
Form sagt er, dass Wissen eher
als ein Instrument angesehen wird, mit dem man
das Absolute ergreift, denn als Medium,
durch das man es entdeckt,
glaubt er, dass keine Darstellung dieser
allgemeinen Form grundlegende
erkenntnistheoretische Kriterien der Angemessenheit erfüllen kann  indem er
zeigt, dass er hofft, seine
Leser die Notwendigkeit eines
alternativen Modells erkennen zu lassen, dem er
dann den allgemeinen Charakter verleiht  seiner
Beschwerde gegen die Konstruktion kognitiver
Fähigkeiten auf dem Instrumenten- oder
Medienmodell scheint klar genug, dass er eine
zweifache Zusammenfassung bietet, dass das Modell zunächst
zu der Überzeugung führt, dass es eine
Absurdität in dem Konzept gibt,
einen Erkenntnisprozess überhaupt zu beginnen, der
darauf abzielt, dies für das Bewusstsein zu gewinnen
was an sich liegt, und zweitens, dass
es eine strenge
Trennlinie zwischen Wissen und dem Absoluten gibt,
behauptet der erste Einwand, dass
Theorien der Art, die er anspricht,
zu einer Art Skepsis führen müssen, ein Versäumnis
, die Idee, zu wissen,
wie die Dinge sind, verständlich zu machen  selbst die zweite
Beschwerde deutet auf eine Diagnose eines
Grundes für dieses Scheitern hin, das Modell
gräbt eine Kluft
aus, die das
Bewusstsein von dem trennt, worüber Professor
Hooker gerade unter der
Überschrift des Mythos des Gibbon Hegel gesprochen hat, und
erweitert diese beiden Punkte, die er ausfüllt  im
Vorwurf, dass Instrumenten- oder
Medientheorien zu Skepsis führen, indem sie
zitaten, wenn kn  Das Wissen ist das Instrument,
um das absolute Wesen zu erfassen, wenn
es sofort daran erinnert wird, dass die
Anwendung eines Instruments auf eine Sache
es nicht belässt, sondern
eine Formung und Veränderung bewirkt,
oder wenn Wissen kein Instrument für
unsere ist  Aktivität, sondern ein mehr oder weniger passives
Medium, durch das uns das Licht der Wahrheit
erreicht, dann empfangen wir diese Wahrheit nicht so,
wie sie ist,
sondern so, wie sie ist, in und durch dieses Medium,
in beiden Fällen verwenden wir ein Mittel, das das
unmittelbar bewirkt  Das Gegenteil von
seinem eigenen Zweck oder vielmehr die Absurdität liegt
darin, dass wir am Ende des Zitats jedes Mittel verwenden,
in jedem Fall wird es einen
Unterschied geben zwischen dem, was Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, das Produkt der
Ausübung kognitiver Fähigkeiten, und dem, was
sie sind  an sich die Rohstoffe,
auf denen diese kognitiven Fähigkeiten
ausgeübt werden, etwas über den
Charakter dieser Unterscheidung, von dem Hegel zu argumentieren scheint,
mit welchen Dingen unvereinbar ist
für ein solches bewusstseinsbild gilt
als echtes wissen,
wie die dinge an sich wirklich sind
er führt das problem aus, das
in der gerade gelesenen passage diagnostiziert wurde,
nämlich dass das instrument oder das medium
bildzitat vorstellungen über das
wissen als instrument und a voraussetzt  Medium
und auch die Vorstellung, dass es einen
Unterschied zwischen uns und dem
Geschäftswissen gibt, aber vor allem
setzt es voraus, dass das Absolute auf der
einen Seite steht und das Wissen, obwohl
es auf der anderen Seite für sich und
vom Absoluten getrennt ist,
dennoch etwas Wirkliches ist, daher
davon ausgeht, dass Wissen
trotz seiner Voraussetzung, dass
Wissen außerhalb des Absoluten
und damit auch außerhalb der Wahrheit liegt, wahr sein kann, indem
er diese Position einnimmt,
offenbart sich das, was sich die Angst vor dem Irrtum nennt, als die
Angst vor der Wahrheit, die eine andere berühmte Passage von
Professor Wurf wiederholte
des Wesens dieses Instruments oder
Mediummodells, um einen solchen Unterschied zu sehen  Eine
Trennung zweier Seiten einer Kluft und
um die Aufgabe einer kognitiven
Fakultät darin zu verstehen, diese Kluft zu überbrücken,
scheint das Argument hier zu sein,
dass, wenn es eine Kluft gibt, die trennt, wie die
Dinge an sich sind, und wie
sie für das Bewusstsein sind, das die
Operation von erfordert  kognitiven Fähigkeiten,
um es zu überbrücken oder die beiden Seiten wieder zu vereinen, dann ist
alles, was die Untersuchung dieser
Fähigkeiten tun kann, die Kluft oder die Trennung wiederherzustellen, die
wir, glaube ich, in diesen Passagen sehen können,
um die allgemeine Form eines Arguments zu formen,
aber es ist verschwommen und schwer zu erkennen
Sowohl die genauen Umrisse der Klasse von
Ansichten, auf die es abzielt, als auch die Art und Weise, wie ihre
Kritik funktionieren soll,
die Unschärfe der Argumente ist meines Erachtens
teilweise auf die Komprimierung der
Darstellung und teilweise auf die
metaphorischen Begriffe zurückzuführen, in denen sie
geführt wird  füllen Sie die Details aus
, die man angeben müsste, welche
Angemessenheitskriterien für erkenntnistheoretische Theorien
Hegel auf welcher Klasse von
Theorien beharrt  genau er behauptet
, diese Kriterien nicht erfüllen zu können und welche
Merkmale dieser Theorien für
dieses Scheitern verantwortlich sind und wie genau das
Argument für diese Schlussfolgerung funktioniert,
biete ich im Rest dieses Vortrags eine Möglichkeit,
das Argument zu schärfen, das Hegel
hier auf den Tisch legt  dieser
vier Dimensionen und auch eine erste
Charakterisierung der Form des
alternativen Modells, das Hegel vorschlägt,
um das Instrumenten- oder Medienmodell
zu ersetzen, um eine bessere Spezifizierung der
Bandbreite erkenntnistheoretischer Theorien zu erhalten,
die in den Zielbereich von Hegels
Argumentation fallen, als was er metaphorisch
bezeichnet wird  Das Instrumenten- oder
Mediummodell Es wird helfen, etwas weiter hinten zu beginnen.
Die Theorien, die er
anspricht, sind Repräsentationstheorien
der Beziehung zwischen Erscheinung und
Realität
Erscheinungen geometrischer
Realitäten Descar  tes brauchte eine neue Art
, die Beziehungen zwischen
Erscheinung und Realität zu begreifen. Seine philosophische
Antwort auf die wissenschaftlichen und
mathematischen Fortschritte im
Verständnis dieser intellektuell turbulenten und
aufregenden Zeit war die Entwicklung eines
Konzepts der Repräsentation, das
viel abstrakter, kraftvoller und flexibler war als
die Ähnlichkeit  Modell der Antike
und des Mittelalters, das ersetzt hatte,
sah er, dass das, was das algebraische
Verständnis geometrischer Figuren
ermöglichte, ein globaler Isomorphismus
zwischen dem gesamten System der
Braig-Symbole und dem gesamten System
geometrischer Figuren war, wobei der
Isomorphismus einen gemeinsamen Begriff von Form definierte
die erlaubte Manipulation von Ketten
algebraischer Symbole und die
mit geometrischen Figuren möglichen Konstruktionen im
Kontext eines solchen Isomorphismus, die
besonderen materiellen Eigenschaften dessen, was
nun als Repräsentanten von
x' und Repräsentanten verständlich wird, werden
für die semantische Beziehung zwischen ihnen irrelevant, worauf
es ankommt  ist die Wechselbeziehung
zwischen den Regeln, die die
Manipulation der Repräsentation von x' regeln, und
den tatsächlichen Möglichkeiten,
die die Repräsentanten charakterisieren. Inspiriert
von den neu entstehenden Formen des modernen
wissenschaftlichen Verständnisses kam Descartes zu dem
Schluss, dass diese Repräsentationsbeziehung,
von der der alte Begriff der
Ähnlichkeit dann nur noch als eine erscheint
primitive Spezies ist der Schlüssel zum
Verständnis der Beziehungen zwischen Geist
und Welterscheinung in der Realität ganz
allgemein war dies eine fabelhafte Tradition,
die Idee und alles, was westliche
Philosophen gedacht haben, seitdem nicht weniger
auf der praktischen und auf der theoretischen
Seite gedacht hat, ist ihr konzeptionell
und nicht nur nachgelagert  vorübergehend, aber Descartes
kombinierte diese Idee mit einer anderen,
problematischeren, nämlich der Idee, dass, wenn
Dinge bekannt oder verstanden werden sollen,
Repräsentation Repräsentation e
ob richtig oder nicht durch
Repräsentation, dann muss es einige
Dinge geben, die bekannt oder nicht
Repräsentation sind  nal e unmittelbar nicht
durch die Vermittlung der Repräsentation von
x' wenn die Repräsentation von x' selbst
nur repräsentational e bekannt sein könnte, indem
sie ihrerseits selbst repräsentiert werden, dann
würde ein bösartiger unendlicher Regress
resultieren, frei könnten wir nur
von einem repräsentierten Ding wissen durch
Wissen um eine Repräsentation davon und
können nur damit rechnen, darüber zu wissen, wenn wir
bereits über eine Repräsentation davon gewusst haben
und so weiter in einer Formulierung, die erst
Jahrhunderte später von Josiah Royce explizit extrahiert wurde,
wenn sogar
Irrtumsverfälschung geschweige
denn Wissen möglich sein muss  dann dachte Descartes,
dass es etwas geben muss, worüber ein
Fehler nicht möglich ist,
etwas, von dem wir nicht wissen
, dass wir es darstellen, so dass ein Fehler im
Sinne einer falschen Darstellung möglich ist,
wenn wir
etwas Repräsentatives e durch
das Medium der Darstellung von x wissen oder falsch liegen können  „
Davon muss es einige geben, die x darstellen“, die
wir sofort verstehen oder kennen,
einfach indem wir die haben  Das
Ergebnis war eine zweistufige
Repräsentationstheorie, die scharf
zwischen zwei Arten von Dingen unterschied, die auf
ihrer intrinsischen Verständlichkeit beruhten. Einige
Dinge, paradigmatisch, physische,
materielle, erweiterte Dinge, können ihrer
Natur nach nur erkannt werden, indem sie
repräsentiert werden, andere Dinge sind die Inhalte
unseres eigenen Geistes  Natur, die
x' darstellt und auf andere Weise bekannt sind,
sie sind unmittelbar nicht dadurch bekannt, dass sie
repräsentiert werden, sondern nur,
weil sie vorhanden
sind  Natur, die nur als dargestellt erkennbar
ist, ist in diesem Sinne nicht intrinsisch
verständlich, ihr Auftreten bedeutet nicht
von sich aus, dass irgendjemand etwas weiß oder
versteht, wie ich angedeutet habe. Ich
denke, Descartes wurde zu diesem
Bild von zwei Forderungen getrieben, die einerseits
dem Neuen einen Sinn geben  theoretische
mathematische Wissenschaft, in der die Realität
am besten und wirksamsten erscheinen
könnte  Anspruchsvolle Formen des Verständnisses
seiner Zeit erforderten einen neuen, abstrakteren
Begriff der Repräsentation und die Idee
,
dass wir Dinge am besten kennen und verstehen, indem wir Dinge auf angemessene Weise darstellen, also
müssen wir zwischen der Repräsentation von
x' und den Repräsentanten
und unterscheiden  Sorgen um die Beziehungen zwischen
ihnen, aufgrund derer die Manipulation des
einen als Wissen oder
Verstehen des anderen
gilt, droht einem solchen zweistufigen Modell andererseits
die Unverständlichkeit in
Form eines drohenden unendlichen
Erklärungsregresses, wenn wir es nicht tun
Da wir nicht unterscheiden, wie wir wissen, dass wir
durch unsere Relationen zur Repräsentation von x' von
ihnen vertreten sind, und wie wir zumindest einige Repräsentantenjagden
sofort kennen, zumindest nicht,
indem wir mit der Repräsentation von x' von ihnen in Verbindung stehen, war
das Ergebnis ein zweistufiges Modell
die auf die
Repräsentation von x' unmittelbar bezogen waren
und kraft ihrer Beziehung auf
Repräsentierte in einem vermittelten
Erkenntnisverhältnis zu den Repräsentierten stehen
die dinge, die x' repräsentieren, müssen
als intrinsisch und
unmittelbar verständlich verstanden werden, und das
repräsentierte ist nur in einem
abgeleiteten kompositorischen sinn verständlich als das
ergebnis des produkts unserer unmittelbaren
beziehung zu repräsentierenden x' und ihrer
beziehung zu repräsentierenden
ich möchte sagen, dass es dies ist
Erkenntnistheoretisches Modell, das Hegel
in seinen einleitenden Bemerkungen in
der Einleitung zur Phänomenologie
zum Ziel hat, beanstandet er eine zweistufige
Repräsentationstheorie,
die einem fundamentalen Unterschied in der
Verstehbarkeit von Erscheinungen verpflichtet ist,
die x' darstellen, wie die Dinge für
Bewusstsein und Realität sind  das
dargestellte x' wie die Dinge an sich sind
, wonach ersteres
unmittelbar und an sich
verständlich ist und letzteres oder nicht, aber
Hegel davon spricht, ist die Kluft der
Unterschied die Trennung die zwei
Seiten eines trennenden Scheins in
Wirklichkeit wissend im Bekannten, dass er
beklagt wird eben dieser Golf von
Int  Zulässigkeit seiner kritischen Behauptung ist,
dass jede Theorie dieser Form zum Scheitern verurteilt ist
geheilt skeptisch Ergebnisse Natürlich ist
Descartes Sphäre nicht die einzige, die
dieser Kontinent, die Hegel zu kritisieren meint,
Kant
hat auch eine zweistufige
Repräsentationstheorie, als die kognitive Aktivität
verstanden werden muss  Das Produkt sowohl der
Aktivitäten des Verstandes,
Repräsentationen im Sinne der
Repräsentation von x' zu manipulieren, als auch der Beziehungen, die die
Repräsentanten zu dem darstellen, was sie
repräsentieren, sowohl was der Verstand mit
seinen Repräsentationen macht als auch wie sie
mit dem, was sie uns repräsentieren, in Beziehung stehen,
werden bei der Zuweisung von
Verantwortung berücksichtigt  für Merkmale von denen,
die x' repräsentieren, zu den
repräsentierten Dingen, wie sie in einem Vokabular spezifiziert sind
, das weder die geistige
Manipulation von Repräsentationen noch die
Beziehungen zwischen der Repräsentation von x' und
Repräsentanten
hervorruft, das sind Dinge, wie sie sind, wie Conn
uns beigebracht hat, in sich selbst zu sagen,
Hansie  oder zu den
Repräsentationsverhältnissen und was die kognitiven
Fähigkeiten  mit letzteren zu tun und zu
repräsentieren ergibt für Kant, was die
repräsentierten Dinge für das Bewusstsein
in Hegels Terminologie Inhalt für die
Repräsentation von x sind
seine Repräsentation von x' und seine
Beziehung zu Repräsentanten, die
durch diejenigen vermittelt wird, die x' repräsentieren.
Obwohl Katze manchmal zu glauben scheint,
dass wir eine besondere Art von Zugang zu
den Produkten unserer eigenen kognitiven
Aktivität haben, denkt er nicht an unser
Bewusstsein, x zu repräsentieren  „So
unmittelbar in jedem erkennbaren cartesianischen
Sinne ist für ihn Bewusstsein eine Wahrnehmung
und die Mindesteinheit einer Wahrnehmung
Urteil zu beurteilen, besteht für Kant darin
, einen begrifflich artikulierten
Inhalt in eine Konstellation von
Verpflichtungen zu integrieren, die die unverwechselbare
synthetische Einheit einer Wahrnehmung aufweist, die
das tut  aus der Konstellation
der mit den Richtern unvereinbaren Verpflichtungen
hervortreten
Dies ist ein Prozess, der
durch die Beziehungen materieller
Unvereinbarkeit und Konsequenzen vermittelt wird,
die die in den
Urteilen verwendeten Konzepte mit den in
anderen möglichen Urteilen verwendeten Konzepten in Beziehung setzen  Kant teilt
mit Descartes die zweistufige
Repräsentationsstruktur, aber er
übernimmt nicht die Ansicht, dass unsere Beziehung
zu unseren eigenen Repräsentationen eine
unmittelbar bewusste ist, dennoch fällt seine Ansicht
in den Bereich von Hegels Kritik,
weil er an der differentiellen
Verständlichkeit der Repräsentation von x festhält.  und
Repräsentanten, die x' als solches oder
verständlich darstellen und was repräsentiert wird, ist
als solches nicht ich nenne dies ein Bekenntnis
zu einer starken differentiellen Verständlichkeit
des Erscheinens in Wirklichkeit die Behauptung, dass
das eine die richtige Art von Dingen ist, um
verständlich zu sein, und das andere ist  not
cat gibt uns ein neues Modell der
Verständlichkeit, um intelligib zu sein  B.
einen durch Konzepte artikulierten Inhalt zu haben, sind
es die Konzepte, die in einem Akt des
Bewusstseins einer Wahrnehmung angewendet werden, die bestimmt haben,
was als erfolgreiche
Integration dieses Urteils in ein Ganzes gelten würde,
das die charakteristische synthetische
Einheit einer Wahrnehmung aufweist, aber die konzeptionelle
Artikulation von Urteilen ist eine Form
von der kognitiven Fakultät
des Verstehens beigetragen, ist es nicht etwas, was
wir wissen oder annehmen können, um zu charakterisieren,
was durch diese konzeptuellen
Repräsentanten repräsentiert wird, da sie
nach hinkels Lektüre Kant
einer Kluft der Verständlichkeit verpflichtet sind, die unsere
Repräsentation von x' von dem trennt, was sie
repräsentieren  in Form der Auffassung,
dass das Repräsentieren des Zaren in begrifflicher
Gestalt und das Dargestellte, wie die
Dinge an sich sind, nicht nur daran
erinnern soll, wie viel in Hegels Kritik daran auf dem Spiel steht
,
repräsentationstheoretische Theorien über die
Beziehungen zwischen Schein und Wirklichkeit
zu inszenieren  sind der differentiellen
Intelligenz verpflichtet  fähigkeit der relati es lohnt sich
, in diesem zusammenhang auch an franca zu denken,
denn franca diskursive symbole
drücken einen sinn aus sünde und bezeichnen damit
einen referenten die deuter sinne
sind das, was erfasst wird, wenn man
den ausdruck und bezug versteht, was
dadurch repräsentiert wird, was diesen
sinn ausdrückt  das Reden oder Denken über einen
Sinn ist ein Darstellen
insofern, als er eine Darstellungsweise aus düsteren Gaben Zeichen eines Referenten nennt, so wenig
wie Kant Frager das Erfassen
eines Sinnes als unmittelbar im kartesischen
Sinne auffaßt, wonach das bloße
Auftreten von  Etwas mit diesem Sinn
gilt als der Verstand, der etwas weiß oder
versteht, eher
um einen Inhalt zu begreifen, erfordert die Beherrschung
der schlussfolgernden und substitutionellen
Beziehungen, die der Sinn zu anderen
Inhalten hat, aber wie Descartes und Kant
denkt Frege, dass das Begreifen von
Sinnen, das Verstehen von Repräsentationen als
Repräsentationen
, deren Repräsentation erfordert  wiederum und
die Vertretung  nting x' im Sinne von
Sinnen unser Ergreifbares in einem Sinne, in dem das,
was sie darstellen, nicht so ist, wenn Hegels Argumentation, wie ich geplant habe,
auf zweistufige Repräsentationsmodelle gerichtet sein soll, die darauf
verpflichtet sind
, Repräsentationen in einem Sinne als verständlich zu behandeln,
in dem sie den Zaren repräsentierten  nicht
dann scheint es, dass die Phryger sich sowohl
auf die Theorien als auch auf den Inhalt beziehen,
und kartesische Versionen werden jetzt
zu den Zielen von Hegels Argumentation gehören,
um zu sehen, ob es ein
Argument der Art gibt, wie Hegel nach den
Aussagen gegen Theorien dieser Art
zwei-  Bühnenrepräsentationstheorien
, die der starken differentiellen
Verständlichkeit der Repräsentation von Zand-
Repräsentanten verpflichtet sind, müssen wir als nächstes darüber nachdenken, auf
welche Angemessenheitskriterien für solche
Theorien Hegel sich beruft
Skepsis
weiter sagt er uns, dass er damit meint,
dass solche Theorien ausschließen
, Dinge zu wissen a  Da sie in sich selbst sind,
denke ich, was hier vor sich geht, ist, dass
Hegel von Kant gelernt hat, dass der weiche
Unterbauch erkenntnistheoretischer
Theorien die semantischen Theorien sind, die sie
implizit beinhalten und von denen sie abhängen,
und er denkt, dass die zweistufigen
Repräsentationstheorien
der starken differentiellen Verständlichkeit verpflichtet sind
Zinn zu repräsentieren, was sie repräsentieren,
schließt semantisch echtes
Wissen dieser Repräsentanten aus. Ich nenne das
Kriterium der Angemessenheit und
erkenntnistheoretische Theorien, die Hegel
hier implizit anruft, die echte
Wissensbedingung
GKC. Offensichtlich wird sich viel um das drehen,
was als echtes Wissen gilt, aber
es ist  Jedenfalls ist klar, dass diese
Forderung verlangt, dass eine
erkenntnistheoretische Theorie nicht
auf eine Semantik, insbesondere auf
eine Repräsentationstheorie festgelegt wird, die sich bei genauem
Hinsehen als unverständlich herausstellt, dass überhaupt
die Möglichkeit, zu
wissen, wie die Dinge wirklich sind,
ich tue, als unverständlich ausgeschlossen wird  nicht nehmen, dass die Existenz
von  Ein Kontrast zwischen dem, wie wir wissen, was
repräsentiert wird, und dem, wie wir wissen, dass das
Repräsentieren an sich ist, zeigt ein solches Versagen
Hegels spezifische Behauptung ist, dass, wenn dieser
Unterschied als einer der
Verständlichkeit im strengen Sinne ausgelegt wird,
der Zar an sich
verständlich und der repräsentierte Zar
nicht skeptisch gegenüber echt ist  Wissen
ist eine Konsequenz und er nimmt von Muschel
die Idee, dass Verständlichkeit eine
Frage der begrifflichen Artikulation ist.
Verständlich zu sein bedeutet, in begrifflicher
Form
zu sein  nicht
nur Schein, wie die Dinge
subjektiv für das Bewusstsein sind, sondern auch Realität,
wie die Dinge objektiv an sich sind,
als begrifflich artikuliert wieder,
was als gutes Argument für diese
Behauptung gelten könnte, dreht sich offensichtlich um das, was erforderlich ist
, um diese Anforderung zu erfüllen,
sowohl Ähnlichkeits- als auch
Repräsentationsmodelle der Beziehungen b  zwischen
Schein und Wirklichkeit haben eine Geschichte
darüber, worin der Fehler besteht,
das passiert, wenn auf dem Ähnlichkeitsbild
vorweg verständliche
Eigenschaften nicht geteilt werden, so dass die
Ähnlichkeit zusammenbricht, oder wenn es
zu lokalen Zusammenbrüchen im global
definierten Isomorphismus zwischen den Systemen
der Darstellung von x kommt.  und Repräsentanten in
den mittleren Absätzen der
Einleitung, in denen Hegel damit beginnt
, seine Alternative zu zweistufigen
repräsentationalen erkenntnistheoretischen
Theorien vorzustellen, die sich einer starken
differentiellen Verständlichkeit der
Repräsentation von x' und Repräsentanten verschrieben haben, spielt die
Behandlung von Fehlern eine große Rolle. Ich denke,
wir können sie als implizit annehmen
Angemessenheitskriterium, das Hegel
erkenntnistheoretischen Theorien auferlegt, dass sie
auch das Phänomen nicht
nur echter Erkenntnis, sondern auch des
Irrtums verständlich machen, nenne ich die
Verständlichkeitsbedingung die echte
Erkenntnisbedingung und die Verständlichkeit der
Irrtumsbedingung unsere erkenntnistheoretischen
Zwänge das sem  Possen, die von
einer erkenntnistheoretischen Theorie vorausgesetzt oder implizit sind,
müssen Hegel uns sagt,
weder die Verständlichkeit von echtem
Wissen noch von Irrtümern darüber ausschließen,
wie die Dinge wirklich sind, wir müssen in der Lage sein zu
verstehen, was es ist, damit
es so erscheint  ist, und dass es
so aussieht, als wäre es keine
erkenntnistheoretische Theorie,
die beides nicht verständlich macht, ist
dem Phänomen unserer
Bemühungen, zu wissen und zu verstehen, wie die
Dinge wirklich sind
, nicht angemessen, aber die Annäherung an die Erkenntnistheorie, wie Khan
aus dieser semantischen Richtung vorschlägt, legt dies
nahe  hinter diesen
erkenntnistheoretischen Zwängen stehen tiefere
semantische. Ich denke, das ist hier tatsächlich
der Fall, wir können diese nicht aus
Hegels äußerst telegrafischen Bemerkungen
im Text der einleitenden Absätze ablesen,
sondern müssen sie
aus der Lösung erschließen, die er letztendlich
vorschlägt  Die Herausforderungen, die er dort
zuerst angeht, könnten
wir Frager the mod über die Schulter schauen  e der
Präsentationsbedingung ist dies die
Anforderung, dass Erscheinungssinne,
die x' darstellen, im Wesentlichen und
nicht nur zufällige Erscheinungen
einiger angeblicher Realitäten sein müssen. Man zählt nicht
, dass man eine Erscheinung richtig erfasst hat
, es sei denn, man erfasst sie als die
Erscheinung von etwas,
wenn alles gut geht  Die
Erscheinung wurde als ein Weg gezählt, um zu
wissen, was eine Erscheinung
von Erscheinungen ist, muss eine Art von
Realität semantisch sichtbar oder auf
andere
Weise zugänglich machen
Nur in Bezug auf das Sein ist das
kein dummer Gedanke, aber es ist nicht der
gegenwärtige Punkt. Die gegenwärtige Idee ist, dass,
wenn die erkenntnistheoretische
Bedingung für echtes Wissen durch ein
zweistufiges
Repräsentationsmodell erfüllt werden soll, Repräsentanten semantische
Präsentationen von Repräsentanten
in einer robusten sein müssen  Sinne, in dem das, was man
erfasst, keine Repräsentation ist, es sei denn  Wenn
es als Repräsentation von etwas
Repräsentiertem verstanden wird, werden wir weiter unten sehen, wie
Hegel
diese Anforderung versteht,
etwas in der Praxis zu
nehmen oder zu behandeln, da ein Repräsentant es einer
bestimmten Art von normativer Bewertung
hinsichtlich seiner Richtigkeit unterwirft  In einer Weise, in der das,
was dabei zählt, repräsentiert wird,
dient es als Maßstab für die normative
Beurteilung der
Richtigkeit  Um
semantisch so verstanden zu werden, dass
echtes Wissen unterstützt werden
kann, muss
es das Dargestellte so darstellen, dass es einen rationalen Zwang zur Darstellung ausübt, zu dem es so ist, wie es
mit dem Dargestellten ist, muss, wenn die
Repräsentationsbeziehung nicht fehlerhaft ist
, einen Grund für die Repräsentation für
die Repräsentation liefern  zu sein, wie es ist, was
wir'  darüber zu sprechen oder darüber nachzudenken muss in der
Lage sein, Gründe für das zu liefern, was wir darüber sagen
oder denken. Wir können dies die
Bedingung der rationalen Einschränkung nennen, obwohl er
in der Einleitung nicht für diese Einschränkung argumentiert.
Ich denke, in vielerlei Hinsicht ist es
die Schlüsselprämisse für die
dass Hegel den Gedanken anbietet,
dass der Unterschied zwischen der bloß
unterschiedlichen Reaktion auf das
Vorhandensein oder Nichtvorhandensein einer Tatsache oder
Eigenschaft einerseits und dem
Verstehen dessen, Gedanken
darüber zu haben, in dem Sinne, dass es als
Wissen gilt, wenn alles gut geht,
davon abhängt  Die Möglichkeit, dass dieser
Faktor Eigenschaft
dem Wissenden als Grund dienen kann, eine
Überzeugung zu haben oder eine Verpflichtung
einzugehen,
hängt von der Fähigkeit ab, rational zu erfassen
, wie die Dinge sind, im Sinne einer
Bereitstellung  Gründe für unsere
Einstellung diejenigen unter Ihnen, die
mit der Arbeit meines Kollegen John
McDowell vertraut sind, wir werden Resonanzen in dieser
Sprache hören, die Hegel lernt  von Kant
über Repräsentation in normativen Begriffen nachzudenken,
was repräsentiert wird, übt eine
besondere Autorität über das
Repräsentieren aus Repräsentieren unsere
normativ verantwortlich für das, was sie
repräsentieren, was repräsentiert wird, dient als eine
Art maßgeblicher normativer Maßstab
für die Beurteilung der Richtigkeit dessen,
was davon repräsentiert wird
richtig oder falsch, nur weil
sie Bewertungen ihrer Richtigkeit unterliegen,
bei denen diese
Repräsentanten den Standard liefern
, fügt die rationale Nebenbedingung hinzu, dass
der Standard, der repräsentiert wird
, Gründe für diese normativen
Bewertungen liefern muss, was im Kontext
konstanter Hegel-Ansichten tatsächlich nicht der Fall ist  eine
weitere verpflichtung für keine von beiden
unterscheidet zwischen normen oder regeln
einerseits und normen sind regeln,
die rational im sinne von
begrifflich artikuliert sind andererseits
alle normen sind für sie als
begriffsnormen zu verstehen normen oder regeln und
begriffe sind nur zwei  wa  ys des Nachdenkens
über dasselbe
begriffliche Normen sind Normen, die
bestimmen, was ein Grund dafür ist,
wofür eine Norm
begrifflichen Inhalt haben soll, eine Frage dessen,
wofür oder dagegen und
was ein Grund sein kann  für unsere dagegen ist
das eben die einzige art von inhalt groß,
die der deutsche id auflistet ein rationalist
über normen darin, dass normen oder regeln
inhalt sind 'fl ausschließlich im sinne
, begriffsinhalt zu sein, denn die
rationale beschränkungsbedingung
füllt dementsprechend im sinne der
darstellung aus  oder Aboutness, von der die
Art der Darstellungsbedingung abhängt,
und diese beiden semantischen Bedingungen
liefern die entscheidenden Kriterien der Angemessenheit
für die Erfüllung der beiden erkenntnistheoretischen
Bedingungen der Bedingung des echten Wissens
und der Bedingung der Verständlichkeit des
Irrtums für die Verständlichkeit
des echten Wissens oder des Irrtums darüber,
wie die Dinge wirklich sind  are dreht sich um den
rationalen normativen Zwang, den diese
Realitäten auf das ausüben, was als
ap gilt  Wahrnehmungen oder Darstellungen dieser
Realitäten nur insoweit, als der
vertretende Zar einer normativen
Beurteilung der Richtigkeit und in der
Richtigkeit Kenntnis und Irrtum unterliegt, in denen
diese Realitäten als Maßstab
im Sinne der Begründung dieser
Beurteilungen dienen, wohl vorausgesetzt, dass diese
vier Bedingungen erkenntnistheoretisch in
Semantik stellt das relevante
Angemessenheitskriterium für erkenntnistheoretische
Theorien und deren implizite Semantik dar,
was letztlich das Argument gegen
zweistufige Repräsentationstheorien ist
, die sich einem starken
Unterschied der Verständlichkeit zwischen
Repräsentation von x' und Repräsentanten von
Schein und Wirklichkeit verschrieben haben
diese Form erfüllt im Prinzip
von den vier Angemessenheitskriterien
ihre Charakteristik zweistufiger Theorien,
nicht nur de cartes, sondern auch die von
Kant und Frager, dass sie eine
Unterscheidung zwischen zwei Arten des Wissens
oder Verstehens von Dingen beinhalten, manche Dinge
sind nur repräsentativ und durch Sein bekannt
repräsentiert andere Dinge zumindest einige
repräsentieren x' nach dem
Regressargument sind bekannt nicht-repräsentative
e auf andere Weise als durch
Repräsentiertheit Wenn wir daran interessiert sind
, kognitive Fähigkeiten im
Kontext solcher Theorien zu untersuchen, sind wir
am Ende interessiert  In der Semantik sind
die Repräsentationsrelais
für die kognitiven Fähigkeiten das
Instrument oder Medium, das die
Repräsentation von z' des Realen erzeugt, aber dann
müssen wir fragen, ob die Repräsentationsbeziehung
die Beziehung zwischen der
Repräsentation von z' und dem, was sie
selbst darstellen, etwas ist, das als
Repräsentation bekannt ist e oder  ist es etwas
, das nicht gegenständlich erkannt werden kann,
wenn es selbst etwas ist, das nur erkennbar oder
verständlich ist, wenn es dargestellt
wird, scheint es, dass wir uns auf einen
bösartigen Bradley einlassen und einen Rückschritt machen, ein Nachfolger desjenigen,
um den Descartes besorgt war.
Das erkenntnistheoretische Unternehmen ist nicht
verständlich, es sei denn  Wir können
die Beziehung zwischen Repräsentationen semantisch verstehen
von Repräsentationsbeziehungen
und diesen Repräsentationsbeziehungen
und dann Repräsentationen
dieser Relationen und so weiter, bis wir
die ganze unendliche Kette von
Repräsentationen erfasst haben zuv Repräsentieren zuv
Repräsentieren wir nicht in der Lage sind,
die Repräsentationsbeziehung zu verstehen
und daher nicht das Instrument oder  Medium
der Repräsentation Semantik Skepsis
Skepsis darüber, was es ist,
etwas zu repräsentieren, muss
dann das Ergebnis sein. Dieses Argument ist im
Wesentlichen der kartesische Regress des
Repräsentationsarguments für
nichtrepräsentatives Wissen der
Repräsentation von x', aber jetzt nicht nur
auf die Repräsentation von x angewendet  “ Aber in Bezug auf die Beziehung, in der
sie zu dem stehen, was sie
repräsentieren, so scheint es, wenn
Erkenntnistheorie und damit Wissen
verständlich sein sollen, dass wir innerhalb dieser
Art von Rahmen das
andere Horn des Dilemmas umfassen und annehmen müssen,
dass es die Repräsentationsbeziehung ist
etwas, das selbst bekannt oder
verstanden werden kann, non oder pre re  Präsentational e,
aber in dieser Hinsicht gehört es in eine Kiste
mit den Repräsentationen, wo
Erscheinungen selbst auf
diese Weise auf das Dilemma bezüglich unseres
Verständnisses der Repräsentationsbeziehung
antworten, indem sie die
Bedingung der Präsentationsweise dafür anerkennen
, dass sie sagt, dass ein Teil unseres Nicht-Nicht-
Repräsentational ist  das Verstehen von
Erscheinungen, die x' repräsentieren,
muss sie als
Erscheinungen
als Repräsentation von etwas verstehen,
dort Repräsentationseigenschaften von
Nestern, ihre Beziehung zu dem, was sie
zumindest vorgeben zu repräsentieren, muss
in demselben Sinne verständlich sein, in dem
die Repräsentation selbst und die
rationale Zwangsbedingung sind  sagt,
dass Erscheinungen verständlich sein müssen, um vergangene
Erscheinungen zu sein, die x '
Erscheinungsweisen darstellen Darstellungsweisen von
etwas, sie müssen verständlich sein, da sie
rational durch das, was sie darstellen, eingeschränkt sind, dann
bedeutet dies, dass
das Dargestellte verständlich sein muss
, Gründe dafür liefert  Beurteilungen der
Richtigkeit in der Richtigkeit des
Anscheins und der Darstellungsgründe sind
Dinge,
die als Gründe für die
Beurteilung einer Darstellung als
richtig oder falsch als
Wissen oder Irrtum angesehen und gesagt werden können, dh das
, was Gründe für solche
Beurteilungen liefert  muss selbst nicht weniger als die
Bewertungen selbst in konzeptioneller
Form sein. Eine
Verpflichtung zu begründen, zum Beispiel eine Bewertung
der Richtigkeit oder Unrichtigkeit
vorzunehmen, ist eine einfache Argumentation
und Schlussfolgerung, in der die
Prämissen gute Gründe für die Verpflichtung liefern
, Prämissen auszustellen  deren Billigung
zu der Schlussfolgerung berechtigt,
dass die Gründe nicht weniger als das, wofür ihre
Gründe begrifflich artikuliert werden müssen,
anders ausgedrückt,
Erscheinungen müssen in dem
Sinne
verständlich sein, dass sie begrifflich artikuliert werden, um das Urteil zu verstehen,
dass die Dinge so und so sind
wissen, welches Konzept  s angewendet werden
und diese Konzepte verstehen,
wenn dies nur insofern der Fall ist, als man
ihre Rolle praktisch beherrscht, wenn es darum geht, zu
überlegen, was ihre Anwendbarkeit
Gründe für und gegen ihre Anwendbarkeit liefert, und die
Anwendbarkeit dessen, welche anderen Konzepte
Gründe für oder gegen ihre Anwendbarkeit liefern würden,
wenn die Beziehung
zwischen Erscheinungen und  und die
Realitäten ihre Erscheinungen dessen, was sie
darstellen, wie sie die Dinge darstellen
,
da L im gleichen Sinne verständlich sein soll
wie die Erscheinungen
selbst, damit die regressive
Darstellung vermieden wird, dies muss
daran liegen, dass diese Beziehung selbst eine
konzeptionelle Beziehung ist eine Beziehung  unter
Konzepten oder Konzeptanwendungen eine
Beziehung zwischen Dingen, die
konzeptionell artikuliert sind, lautet die Schlussfolgerung,
dass, wenn die rationale Einschränkungsbedingung
erfüllt sein muss,
um die echte Wissensbedingung
und die Verständlichkeitsbedingung des Fehlers zu
erfüllen, wenn die rationale
Einschränkungsbedingung wirklich ein semantisches
n ist  Notwendige Bedingung für die Erfüllung dieser
erkenntnistheoretischen Angemessenheitskriterien,
vielleicht weil es eine notwendige
Bedingung für die Erfüllung der
Darstellungsweise ist, die selbst eine
notwendige semantische Bedingung für die
Erfüllung der erkenntnistheoretischen Bedingung des allgemeinen
echten Wissens und der Bedingung der
Verständlichkeit von Fehlern ist, dann können
diese Bedingungen nicht erfüllt werden
eine zweistufige Repräsentationstheorie
, die sich der starken
differentiellen Verständlichkeit von
Repräsentieren und Repräsentieren verschrieben hat, wenn nicht nur das
Repräsentieren von x', sondern die Repräsentationsbeziehung
in einem Sinne verständlich sein muss
, der ihre konzeptionelle Artikulation erfordert,
dann müssen beide Enden der
Repräsentationsbeziehung
nur konzeptionell Inhalt sein in  auf diese Weise ist
es verständlich, wie das
Dargestellte einen rationalen Zwang auf die
Darstellung von x' ausüben kann, in dem Sinne,
dass es Gründe für Bewertungen
ihrer Korrektheit oder Korrektheit liefert,
was ich heute im Rest meines Vortrags tun möchte,
ist zu beginnen  Um die
alternative Form der Theorie vorzustellen, die
Hegel uns empfehlen wird, habe ich
bisher daran gearbeitet, eine Struktur unter dem zu finden,
was auf der telegrafischen
Oberfläche des Textes der einleitenden Absätze von
Hegels Einleitung erscheint, von der ich bisher behauptete, sie
nur skizziert zu haben  Potenziell
färbbares Argument Weitere
Untersuchung der Gründe für die Annahme
der rationalen Beschränkungsbedingung, die
diese Darstellung als die wichtigste
tragende Prämisse dafür offenbart, ist
eine Schlüsselkomponente dieses Unternehmens,
die die Konzepte der konzeptuellen
Artikulation und des konzeptuellen Inhalts
des Rationalen klären würde  Die Einschränkungsbedingung besagt
, dass sowohl das Darstellende als auch das Dargestellte charakterisiert werden muss,
was das Bekenntnis zu
einer Repräsentationstheorie mit einem starken
Unterschied in der Verständlichkeit verneint
Unterschied der Verständlichkeit
von Schein und Sinn  Dass dies
geleugnet wurde, ist, sobald man sich dazu verpflichtet hat,
keine Kluft der Verständlichkeit
zwischen der Darstellung von x' und dem, was sie
darstellen, zwischen Erscheinung und Realität,
zwischen Geist und Welt
auszuheben, kann man mit Freges Beweis für die vorgeschlagene
Definition in dem Gedanken beginnen, den er sagt a
Tatsache ist ein wahrer Gedanke Gedanken für
Fraga sind die Sinne deklarativer
Sätze ihre Behauptungen im Sinne von
beanspruchbaren Inhalten, anstatt zu behaupten, dass
x' eine Tatsache, die er sagt, nicht etwas
ist, das einem solchen Sinn entspricht oder von ihm repräsentiert wird,
es ist einfach so  ein Sinn ein
Sinn, der wahre Fakten für Frager ist ihr
eine Teilmenge von beanspruchbaren Sinnen, die
die kognitive Erscheinung darstellen
Natürlich behält Frigga das zweistufige
Repräsentationsmodell für die Beziehung
zwischen Sinnen und ihre Referenz für
Gedankenwahrheitswerte bei und dies ist wichtig
für das, was er denkt, dass Sinne sind  nämlich
Weisen der Darstellung von Referenzen,
aber was die Beziehungen zwischen Gedanken
und Tatsachen betrifft, tut er es nicht
Berufung auf ein solches Modell wieder Vic in
Stein sagt in dem möglicherweise John
McDowells Lieblingszitat aus dem
Untersuchungszitat, wenn wir sagen und
meinen, dass dies und das der Fall ist, wir
und unsere Bedeutung nicht vor
der Tatsache Halt machen, aber wir meinen dies
In dem Zitat steckt in diesen Fällen der
Inhalt dessen, was wir sagen, unsere Bedeutung ist
die Tatsache, dass über einen solchen Ansatz manchmal
unter dem Titel einer
Identitätstheorie der Wahrheit gesprochen wird und
manchmal unter dieser
Rubrik John McDowell zugeschrieben wird, obwohl er das nicht
so ist  Würde man auf eine solche Herangehensweise setzen,
gibt es zwischen Schein und Wirklichkeit keinen prinzipiellen Golf der
Verständlichkeit,
denn zumindest wenn alles gut geht,
erben die Scheinen ihren
Inhalt von der Wirklichkeit,
dass sie gefangen sind, dass sie
Gedankenerscheinungen im Sinne des Denkens sein können
Teilen Sie ihren Inhalt mit wahren Gedanken
in einem Sinne des Denkbaren, das sind die
Tatsachen, die sie darstellen und die ZAR
darstellen, die sich von den Repräsentanten, also den
Zweien, unterscheiden  Das Repräsentationsmodell der Tage ist
immer noch in Touristen, aber sie werden
als zwei Formen verstanden, in denen ein Inhalt
manifestiert werden kann. Was meiner Meinung nach am auffälligsten an
Ansichten dieser Art ist, ist, dass
sie sich der Behauptung verschrieben haben, dass sie, wie
McDowell es ausdrückt, in Mind and World stehen
das konzeptionelle hat keine äußere grenze,
was denkbar ist, wird mit dem identifiziert,
was konzeptionell inhaltsreich ist, aber die
objektiven tatsachen nicht weniger als die des
subjektiven denkens und die behauptung „er ist
über sie“ werden als sich selbst
bereits in konzeptueller form verstanden, der frühe
vidkun-stil nicht weniger als das spätere
denken  der Dinge so, als er sagte,
die Welt ist alles, was der Fall ist,
die Gesamtheit der Tatsachen und was
darüber gesagt werden kann
freundliches Umfeld, in dem
die rationale Zwangsbedingung zu
erfüllen ist und so im Rahmen eines
geeigneten Conte und normativ
unter  Das Ansehen der
Darstellungsweise Bedingung für das
Verständnis der Beziehung zwischen kognitiven
Erscheinungen und den Realitäten, in denen
sie Erscheinungen sind, die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
und Plausibilität dieser Art von
Herangehensweise hängen nun hauptsächlich von den
Details des Verständnisses des
Metabegriffs des Begrifflichen ab  Der konzeptionelle
Inhalt bildet das Konzeptkunstzeitalter,
in Bezug auf das es ausbeuterisch ist, dass
einige solcher Konzepte
extrem unplausibel, vielleicht nicht zu
rechtfertigen sind.
Wenn beispielsweise das Verständnis von
Konzepten letztendlich psychologisch ist,
dann würde die Idee, dass Gedanken,
Denken, Glauben und Fakten
denselben konzeptuellen Inhalt haben könnten
unerwünschte Folgen haben, wenn man
bedenkt, dass das, was in erster
Linie begrifflich gehaltvoll ist,
Überzeugungen und Gedanken sind und dass andere
Dinge wie visuelle und auditive Zeichengestaltungen,
Zeichen und Geräusche nur einmal als
begrifflich gehaltvoll gelten können,
indem sie Ausdruck von Überzeugungen sind  und
Gedanken dann droht die Behauptung, dass die Tatsachen, die
diese Überzeugungen und Gedanken und daraus
abgeleitet die Zeichen und Geräusche
ausdrücken, wenn alles gut geht,
selbst konzeptionell zufrieden stellend für diesen
Gedanken sind, die
Existenz dieser Tatsachen, einschließlich solcher, die
niemals ausgedrückt oder dargestellt werden, in
bedenklicher Weise abhängig zu machen  auf die Existenz
des Denkens und des Glaubens
ergibt sich die gleiche unglückliche Art
von Implikation aus der Verbindung der rationalen Beschränkungsversion der
eingeschränkten Darstellungsweise mit Davidsons
Behauptung, dass nur eine Überzeugung eine Überzeugung rechtfertigen kann
Berkeley behauptet, dass die einzigen
Dinge, für die wir intelligent
verstanden werden können  Durch unsere Gedanken
sind andere Gedanken die Gedanken Gottes darstellen
Einige der britischen Idealisten dachten,
dass die Realität, die uns in
Gedanken und im Glauben erschien, aus dem
Gedanken des Absoluten bestehe, und dachten, sie
hätten diese Lektion von Hegel gelernt, in jüngerer
Zeit Derrida, indem sie de Saussures verwendeten
konzeptionell vor Inhalt an  d Die
vorphrygische Terminologie bietet ein Bild
einer Welt, die nur aus Signifikanten besteht,
wobei die einzigen Dinge, die als Signifikanten zur Verfügung stehen
, weitere Signifikanten sind. An
dieser Stelle ist die Sache eindeutig
falsch gelaufen,
wenn Hegels Eingangsargument
in einer solchen Weise ausgefüllt werden muss  des
Idealismus als Folge davon sollten wir
ihn durch modus tollens ausnutzen, nicht durch modus
ponens, obwohl Hegels Idee ist, dass die
Kriterien der Angemessenheit für die Darstellung der
Beziehungen zwischen ihm zwischen Erscheinung
und Realität, die seiner Argumentation zugrunde liegen
, ohne nachteilige Konsequenzen erfüllt werden können,
aber  nur im Kontext
einer anderen, ganz unpsychologischen
Auffassung von begrifflicher Gehaltsfülle ist
die Art von Idealismus, die
einen Weltdenker auf der objektiven Seite nicht
weniger als einen endlichen Denker auf der
subjektiven Seite erfordern würde, tatsächlich für Hegel wie
für uns eine reductio ad absurdum  was
uns aber zu verwerfen verleiten sollte, ist nicht der
Anspruch, den die zweistufigen Repräsentationstheorien
haben müssen  Ohne starke
Unterscheidungen der Verständlichkeit zwischen der
Repräsentation von x' und Repräsentanten zu treffen,
weil sie dann die
Bedingung der semantischen rationalen Beschränkung
und die Bedingung der Darstellungsweise nicht erfüllen können und
damit auch nicht die Bedingung der erkenntnistheoretischen echten
Erkenntnis und die Bedingung der Verständlichkeit
des Irrtums, was wir ablehnen sollten,
ist das Besondere  Konzept der
begrifflichen Artikulation und damit
Verständlichkeit, mit dem sie
verbunden wurden Hegel bezieht seinen Begriff des
begrifflichen Gehalts aus dem Nachdenken über
Kants Urteilstheorie und nimmt Sie mit
auf Khans Verständnis von
Begriffen als Funktionen des Urteilens. Kant
versteht das Urteilen in normativen und
pragmatischen Begriffen auf  die normative seite
versteht er unter urteilen sich verpflichten
, verantwortung für
etwas zu übernehmen den beurteilten inhalt zu billigen
von der pragmatischen seite versteht er dieses
normative tun praktisch
als eine sache dessen, was man sich
verpflichtet oder wofür
man verantwortlich ist  denn das Tun
bedeutet, den befürworteten Inhalt in eine
Konstellation anderer Verpflichtungen zu integrieren, die
die unverwechselbare Einheit einer
Wahrnehmung aufweist, die das Synthetisieren der
Einheit aus den sich dynamisch
entwickelnden Einheitsverpflichtungen hervorbringt, die
materiell unvereinbar mit der neuen
Verpflichtung sind, und das Extrahieren und Befürworten,
also das Hinzufügen von Verpflichtungen, die  sind seine
materiellen
Konsequenzen, das P zu beurteilen, denn Kant
verpflichtet sich, P mit dem zu integrieren,
was man bereits verpflichtet ist,
eine neue Konstellation zu synthetisieren, die
jene rationale Einheit
aufweist, die für die Wahrnehmung einer
Wahrnehmung aus Hegels Sicht charakteristisch ist
, die die Extrusion oder Vertreibung
unvereinbarer Bindungen eine Extraktion ist
und Expansion gemäß konsequenten
Verpflichtungen ist das Einatmen und
Ausatmen der Atemrhythmus, in dem
ein rationales Subjekt lebt und sich entwickelt. Das
Synthetisieren eines normativen Subjekts, das
die für eine Wahrnehmung charakteristische synthetische Einheit aufweisen muss,
ist ein
rationaler Prozess, weil es ein rationaler Prozess ist  Das Urteil
ist mit einem anderen materiell unvereinbar,
es dient als Grund gegen die Billigung
des anderen, und wenn ein Urteil ein
anderes als materielle
Folgerung hat, dient es als Grund dafür
, dieses andere zu billigen, indem es die
Aktivität des Urteilens in Begriffen der
Synthese durch Integration in ein rationales Verständnis versteht
Die Einheit einer Wahrnehmung erfordert, dass die
Urteilenden aller Inhalte in
Relationen materieller Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz für ihre Relationen stehen
, die den
apperzeptiven Prozess der Synthese normativ einschränken, um zu
bestimmen, was als ordnungsgemäße oder
erfolgreiche vollständige Erfüllung der
integrativen Aufgabenverantwortung des
Urteilssubjekts gilt  oder Bindungskonzepte
als Urteilsfunktionen bestimmen,
was als Grund für oder gegen ihre
Anwendbarkeit und was ihre
Anwendbarkeit als Grund für oder
gegen gilt, da dies für alle
Konzepte gilt, nicht nur für formale oder logische,
die Unvereinbarkeit und
folgernde Konsequenz die Konzepte verbindet
bestimmt muster allgemein
verstanden werden als material, das mit den nicht unlogischen inhalten der begriffe zu tun hat,
nicht nur als logisch,
was mit ihrer logischen form zu tun hat
Konsequenz in Bezug auf die Normen, die solche
Inhalte dem Urteilsprozess auferlegen,
als rationale
Integrale liefern sie Standards für die
normative Bewertung solcher Integration
als Korrektor erfolgreiches Erledigen dessen, wozu
man sich verpflichtet hat oder wofür man
sich verantwortlich gemacht hat,
indem es bestätigt wird  ein Richter aller Inhalte, aber
ich sagte auch, dass Hegels Begriff des
Begriffsinhalts kein
psychologischer ist, könnte man mit der Behauptung meinen,
dass das, was Begriffsinhalt artikuliert,
normative Beziehungen sind, die eine Frage dessen sind,
was man tun sollte, und nicht
etwas, das sofort gelesen werden kann
von dem, was man tatsächlich tut oder wozu man bereit ist
, gehört diese Unterscheidung
tatsächlich zum e  Sinn für Kant und
weiter für Hegel, aber bei Hegel
erweist sich dieser Zugang zu Begriffsinhalten in einem viel robusteren Sinne als nicht-psychologisch,
weil er sieht,
dass er nicht nur den
Denkprozess auf der subjektiven
Seite des intentionalen Nexus, sondern auch charakterisiert
was auf der objektiven
Seite für objektive Eigenschaften gedacht wird und damit die
Tatsachen, welche Objekte
welche Eigenschaften aufweisen, stehen auch in
Relationen materieller Inkompatibilität und
Konsequenz
und die Folge, dass
die beiden Körper, die keinen anderen
Kräften ausgesetzt sind, kollidieren, ist eine materiell nichtlineare
Inkompatibilität, die mit ihren Beschleunigungen nicht kompatibel ist,
dass sich die
Beschleunigung eines massiven Objekts
ändert, hat als materielle Konsequenz,
dass es im ersten Fall rechtmäßig erforderlich ist, dass eine
Kraft auf es ausgeübt wurde  die
zwei Möglichkeiten die w  Welt könnte nicht nur
gegensätzlich sein, sie unterscheidet sich nicht
nur, es ist unmöglich, also
sagt uns die Newtonsche Physik, dass es nicht logisch ist, dass es
physikalisch unmöglich ist, dass beides
Tatsachen sein sollten, und im zweiten Fall ist es
physikalisch notwendig,
dass wenn  eine Tatsache
ersterer Art zutreffen würde, würde eine
Tatsache zweiter Art gelten, so folgt, dass,
wenn ich tatsächlich meinen kann, dass
wir mit Hegel in
Relationen von materieller Unvereinbarkeit
und Konsequenz stehen, dann die objektiven Tatsachen
und Eigenschaften,
die uns die Naturwissenschaft als physikalische Realität offenbart  sind selbst
im begrifflichen Schatten modaler Realismus die
Behauptung, dass einige Sachverhalte
andere notwendig machen und andere
unmöglich machen die Anerkennung
von Naturgesetzen beinhaltet begrifflichen Realismus in
diesem Sinne die Behauptung, dass die Art und Weise, wie die
Welt objektiv ist, begrifflich
artikuliert wird, dies eine nicht psychologische
Konzeption ist  des Begrifflichen in einem robusten
Sinne, weil begrifflicher Inhalt
in Relation steht  s materieller
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz
erfordert niemanden, irgendetwas zu denken oder zu glauben
, wenn die Newtonschen Gesetze wahr sind, dann
galten sie, bevor es Denker gab, und
würden gelten, selbst wenn es nie
Denker gab, die von diesen Gesetzen beherrschten Tatsachen
, zum Beispiel frühe Kollisionen von
Teilchen  Gesetzmäßigkeiten
relativer Unmöglichkeit und Notwendigkeit zu
anderen möglichen Tatsachen und damit zu dieser
Auffassung des Begrifflichen hatten
begrifflichen Inhalt, ganz unabhängig
davon, ob irgendwelche subjektiven Denkprozesse
in diesem oder einem anderen Möglichen stattgefunden haben oder jemals stattfinden würden
Welt Hinkle glaubt, dass
diesem Punkt über den
begrifflichen Charakter der objektiven
Realität ein tieferer zugrunde liegt, da er der Meinung ist,
dass die Idee des bestimmten „Nicht-Sitz-
Selbst“ in Bezug auf das
Stehen in Beziehungen der Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz zu anderen Dingen, die
bestimmt sind, zu verstehen ist  im gleichen Sinne
unterstützt er Spinozas Prinzip
Omnis Determinante EO hat Nagat
o Etwas bestimmt zu sein bedeutet, dass
es auf eine Art und nicht auf eine andere
Art und Weise ist. Dieser Gedanke ist in das
Informationskonzept des 20. Jahrhunderts
nach Shannon integriert, das Information
im Hinblick auf die Aufteilung versteht, die jedes
Bit zwischen dem, wie die Dinge gemäß dem sind, festlegt
Informationen und wie
sie sind, sollte nicht jeder zustimmen, dass,
wenn eine Eigenschaft
keine Eigenschaften aufweist, wenn sie sich nicht einmal
von einer von ihnen unterscheidet, es
nur unbestimmt ist zu wissen, dass ein
Objekt eine solche Eigenschaft hat, würde es
bedeuten, nichts darüber zu wissen
Im Wahrnehmungskapitel der
Phänomenologie argumentiert Hegel, dass die
Determinante, die dies bestimmt,
mehr erfordert als bloße Differenz von anderen
Dingen, es erfordert, was er
exklusive Aschendifferenz nennt, und nicht
bloße oder gleichgültige glykolytische
Differenz. Die Eigenschaften Quadrat und
Kreis sind ausschließlich unterschiedliche
Eigenschaften, da Besitz von a  ebene
Figur des einen schließt aus oder
ist materiell i  Unvereinbar mit dem
Besitz des anderen unterscheiden sich die Eigenschaften
Quadrat und Grün lediglich oder
gleichgültig darin, dass, obwohl
sie unterschiedliche Eigenschaften sind, der
Besitz des einen den Besitz des anderen nicht ausschließt,
ein wesentlicher Teil des
bestimmten Inhalts eines Eigentums,
was es zum Eigentum macht  dass es und nicht
irgendetwas anderes ist die Beziehung materiell
stark unvereinbar es steht
in zwei anderen Determinanten Eigenschaften zum
Beispiel Formen zwei andere Formen Farben
zwei andere Farben wir können
die Idee von lediglich unterschiedlichen Eigenschaften
wie quadratisch und grün nur in a verstehen
Kontext, in dem sie in Familien
von Formen und Farben vorkommen, deren Mitglieder ausschließlich voneinander verschieden sind, ist
ein wichtiges Argument für das Verständnis von
Determiniertheit -- Chaos Hegels Weg in Bezug
auf ausschließliche Differenz oder materielle
Inkompatibilität, und eines, dem er
im Wahrnehmungskapitel nachgeht, ist, dass das so ist
was erforderlich ist, um einen
wesentlichen Aspekt der Struktur zu zeichnen  Da
der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen den fundamentalen
ontologischen Kategorien von Objekt und
Eigentum, partikular und universal,
bereits Aristoteles auf eine
strukturelle Asymmetrie zwischen diesen
Kategorien hingewiesen hatte, ist es sinnvoll, sich
jede Eigenschaft als mit einem Gegenstück
im Sinne einer Eigenschaft vorzustellen
, die alle und nur aufweisen  Die Objekte
, die die Indexeigenschaft nicht aufweisen,
haben eine Masse von mehr als fünf Gramm als
Eigenschaft, die in diesem Sinne umgekehrt ist,
aber es macht keinen Sinn,
an Objekte zu denken, die mit kommen,
im analogen Sinne eines
Objekts, das alles aufweist  und nur die
Eigenschaften, die das
Indexobjekt nicht aufweist. Dies liegt genau daran, dass
einige dieser Eigenschaften
miteinander inkompatibel sind und daher
nicht von einem einzelnen Objekt gezeigt werden können.
Die Zahl Neun hat die Eigenschaften
, eine Zahl zu sein, die kein Primzahlwesen ist
ungerade und nicht durch fünf teilbar, wenn
es eine Umkehrung hätte, müsste dieses Objekt
die Eigenschaften haben, nicht a zu sein
Da die Zahl der Primzahlen gerade und
durch fünf teilbar ist, aber
nichts alle diese Eigenschaften haben kann, folgt daraus,
dass eine Welt, die kategorial
bestimmt ist und
bestimmte Eigenschaften und Objekte enthält, und
daher Tatsachen im Sinne von Hegel bestimmt sein müssen, denen
die Eigenschaften standhalten müssen
einander in materiellen
Inkompatibilitätsbeziehungen, wenn sie das tun, werden sie
auch in
materiellen Konsequenzenbeziehungen zueinander stehen, da eine Eigenschaft
P die Eigenschaft Q als
Folge haben wird, wenn alles, was
mit Q nicht kompatibel ist, mit P inkompatibel ist, also ein
Bär ist  Ein Wirbeltier zu sein hat zur
Folge, da alles, was
mit einem Wirbeltier-Sein vereinbar ist, zum
Beispiel eine Primzahl zu sein
, mit einem Bären-Sein unvereinbar ist,
da Hinkle unter
konzeptionell zufrieden sein versteht,
zwei andere solcher Dinge in Beziehungen
materieller Unvereinbarkeit und Konsequenzen
zu nehmen  objektive Welt als
minimal bestimmt im Sinne von
aus Fakten bestehend  darüber, welche
Objekte welche Eigenschaften haben, das heißt, die
Welt in seinem Sinne konzeptuell strukturiert zu nehmen,
für ihn haben nur konzeptionelle
Realisten das Recht, an objektive Realität zu denken,
da der
determinierte modale Realismus so
ziemlich kostenlos ist, wir brauchten die Newtonsche
Physik nicht  Um in diesem Sinne zum konzeptuellen Realismus zu gelangen, ist
der Anwalt detailliert
Metaphysik, das ist bereits genug. Dies ist
die Konzeption des Konzeptuellen im
Kern von Hegels Denken, das
in einem sehr starken Sinne nicht psychologisch ist, und
in diesem Sinne gibt es kein Problem damit
, beide Seiten zu sehen  die Erscheinungs-
Wirklichkeits-Unterscheidung als begrifflich
strukturiert sind wir deswegen nicht
verpflichtet, zwischen ihnen eine Kluft der
Verständlichkeit auszuheben, und aus dem
gleichen Grund ist das
Haupthindernis für die Erfüllung der rationalen
Nebenbedingung und damit der
Darstellungsbedingung
zwar beseitigt  Ich habe noch
nichts Positives darüber gesagt, wie sie
zufrieden sein könnten, das ist t  Das Thema
meines nächsten Vortrags bedeutet aber wiederum,
dass die semantischen Voraussetzungen, die
mir Hegel vorgelesen hat
, es unmöglich machen, die
erkenntnistheoretischen Kriterien der Angemessenheit,
ausgedrückt durch die echte
Erkenntnisbedingung und die Verständlichkeit der
Irrtumsbedingung, auch erfüllen zu können  Der
Zugang zu all diesen wünschenswerten
Konsequenzen soll durch das
nicht-psychologische strukturelle
Verständnis des Begrifflichen in Bezug
auf Beziehungen materieller Inkompatibilität eröffnet werden,
und so ist Konsequenz Hegels Begriff für das, was
ich materielle
Inkompatibilität genannt habe, eine bestimmte Negation
, gegen die tipton  Sie wendet sich an das,
was ich als materielle
Konsequenz bezeichnet habe, ist für Midland
nach der Rolle des Mittelbegriffs in der
klassischen syllogistischen Inferenz das
erste das grundlegendere Konzept
für Hegel, vielleicht teilweise, weil, wie ich
gerade argumentiert habe, überall dort
Inkompatibilitätsbeziehungen bestehen  es wird
Beziehungen von Bedeutung geben, die Hegel oft
co  Kontraste determinierte Negation materielle
Inkompatibilität mit dem, was er
formale oder abstrakte Negation nennt logische
Inkonsistenz Quadrat ist nicht die
determinierte Negation von zirkular wir sind
nicht zirkulär ist die nicht formale
Negation davon das waren
eher aristotelische Gegensätze als widersprüchlich also sind
wir in a  Position, zu sehen, dass die
Wahl des Begriffs bestimmt, um
diesen Unterschied zwischen zwei Arten von
Negation zu kennzeichnen, von Hegels Ansicht motiviert ist, dass
es nur Beziehungen von Determinanten sind,
kraft derer überhaupt etwas
bestimmt ist, dies gilt für
Gedanken ebenso wie für Dinge  von
diskursiven Bindungen auf der subjektiven
Seite der kognitiven Aktivität nicht weniger als
eine Tatsache auf der Seite der objektiven Realität,
das Subjekt kennt ein Axon, weshalb
der Begriff zwar nicht auf psychologischem basiert,
Hegels Metabegriff
des Begrifflichen aber auch für
psychische Zustände gilt  und verarbeitet
Denk- und Glaubensinhalte zu
bestimmten und damit begrifflichen
Inhalten  voll kraft des Stehens zu
anderen möglichen Denkweisen und des Glaubens
an Beziehungen materieller Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenzen, aber unsere subjektiven
Verpflichtungen sind konzeptionell so
in demselben Sinne, dass objektive Tatsachen
sogar auf Heinkels Definition stehen, wenn wir sagen
, dass reines Kupfer und ein
elektrischer Isolator sind  materiell
inkompatibel meinen wir, dass es
physikalisch nicht logisch unmöglich ist, dass
ein Objekt zur
gleichen Zeit beide Eigenschaften hat, aber wenn
wir sagen, dass die Verpflichtung, dass
Hayes reines Kupfer und AIDS ein
elektrischer Isolator ist, materiell
inkompatibel ist, meinen wir das nicht  dass es
für jemanden im selben Fach unmöglich ist,
gleichzeitig
beide Verpflichtungen einzugehen, meinen wir eher, dass,
wenn man ihm beibringt, dies nicht zu tun, dies
die praktische Bedeutung hat, dass ein
Verstoß dagegen bedeutet, dass man
einer nachteiligen normativen Bewertung als jedes
Fach unterliegt  mit zwei
in diesem Sinne materiell unvereinbaren Zusagen ist
o  verpflichtet, etwas zu tun,
um mindestens eine davon aufzugeben oder zu modifizieren,
um die unangemessene Situation zu beheben, aber
es ist immer noch durchaus möglich, dass sich ein
Subjekt in dieser
unangemessenen normativen Situation befindet, und
das heißt, in den Beziehungen der
materiellen Unvereinbarkeit und der Konsequenz
in der Tugend  von denen objektive Tatsachen und
Eigenschaften bestimmt sind mündlich dicke
modale Beziehungen eine Frage dessen, was
bedingt möglich oder unmöglich und
notwendig ist die Beziehungen der materiellen
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz
die von diskursiven Subjekten eingegangenen Verpflichtungen und
Prädikate
bestimmt unsere deontischen
normativen Beziehungen eine Frage dessen, was  man
ist bedingt berechtigt und verpflichtet
, wir können an diese aletha k-- und
deontischen Modalitäten denken, wenn wir möchten, aber es
gibt immer noch sehr unterschiedliche Modalitäten, die
Hegel nach Kant schreibt, der von
der Notwendigkeit spricht, keine Höhe zu finden, da eine
Gattung, die beide Fälle abdeckt, eine Notiz
für Kant findet  bedeutet nach ar  ule er
kann dementsprechend sehen, was er
Naturnotwendigkeit und praktische
Notwendigkeit nannte, eine Art einer Gattung, sie
entsprechen unterschiedlichen Verwendungen des
englischen Wortes müssen, zum Beispiel
müssen dies jedoch sehr unterschiedliche
Modalitäten sein, wesentlich unterschiedliche
Sinn für notwendigen Wert
unterschiedliche Phänomene
zusammengeführt werden und dass die versuchte
Assimilation aus nichts anderem
als der unterschiedslosen Verwendung desselben
verbalen Begriffsbegriffs besteht, der nun eine der
Meta-Verpflichtungen ist, für die ich behauptete, zu
trösten oder
in einem späteren Sinne verständlich zu sein
Nehmen wir, Kunst ist begrifflich zu
strukturieren oder das, was bei dieser breit
strukturell funktionalistischen Darstellung von
Inhalten auf dasselbe
begriffliche Inhalt hinausläuft, denn
Conte Hegel versteht
Verstehen und damit Verständlichkeit in
letztlich pragmatischen Begriffen wiederum als eine Frage dessen,
was man praktisch können muss
zu tun, um als solches zu gelten
zu verstehen, was man tun muss, um
dabei als Erfassen oder Verstehen des
konzeptuellen Inhalts einer diskursiven
Verpflichtung zu gelten, was unternommen wird, bedeutet,
in der Praxis sensibel für die normativen
Verpflichtungen zu sein, die damit verbunden sind, und das bedeutet
, Verpflichtungen anzuerkennen, die ihre
Folgen sind, und diejenigen abzulehnen,
die damit unvereinbar sind  Wie sieht es mit
der Verständlichkeit objektiver
Sachverhalte aus, die konzeptionell
Inhalt sind, weil sie aufgrund der globalen Aletha-
Verbindungen von Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz in andere
solche Sachverhalte eingreifen und nicht die
deontischen normativen Beziehungen,
die
den konzeptuellen Inhalt des entsprechenden
Diskurses artikulieren?  Verpflichtungen ist der entscheidende Punkt, den ich
denke, was man tun
muss, um damit praktisch
als das Annehmen oder Behandeln objektiver Sachverhalte als tödlich unvereinbar zu gelten, ist
genau anzuerkennen, dass man dejanisch ist, wenn man
sich mit den entsprechenden
Verpflichtungen wiederfindet  gezwungen
eine Reform von mindestens einem von ihnen abzulehnen,
und was man tun muss,
um dabei praktisch als das Einnehmen
oder Behandeln eines objektiven
Sachverhalts als notwendige rechtliche
Folge eines anderen zu gelten, ist
die entsprechende Verpflichtung zu einem als
Folge davon anzuerkennen  korrespondierendes
Bekenntnis zum anderen hier
korrespondierende Bekenntnisse sind solche,
deren deontische normative begriffliche
Beziehungen dem Aletha --km-Odel folgen
begriffliche Bezüge der objektiven
Sachverhalte Isomorphismus zwischen
deontischen normativen begrifflichen Bezügen
von Unvereinbarkeit und Konsequenz unter
Bekenntnissen analytische modale Bezüge von
Unvereinbarkeit und Konsequenz untereinander
Sachverhalte bestimmen, wie
man die Dinge objektiv betrachtet, um
die eigenen
Verpflichtungen in Übereinstimmung mit einer bestimmten
Reihe von deontischen Normen der Inkompatibilität praktisch zu erwerben und zu ändern,
und die Konsequenz sind die
objektiv dicken modalen Beziehungen,
die den konzeptuellen Inhalt von
Zuständen artikulieren
wegen dieser Beziehungen die isomorphen zu sein
, eine Verpflichtung
mit einem bestimmten konzeptionellen Inhalt
normativ anzuerkennen, bedeutet, dass die Dinge objektiv
so und so sind, das heißt, eine
bestimmte Tatsache zu erhalten, das heißt
, und das deontische Normative sofort zu erfassen
begrifflicher Inhalt
einer Verpflichtung,
man begreift sie als Erscheinung
einer Tatsache, deren Inhalt durch
die entsprechenden, isomorphen,
modalen Beziehungen von
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz artikuliert wird, so wird
die Bedingung des Darstellungsmodus
in dieser Art von zweistufiger
Repräsentation erfüllt  Modell, während eine
starke Unterscheidung der Verständlichkeit aufgegeben wird
und die rationale Einschränkungsbedingung erfüllt ist,
denn wenn das Subjekt
gefragt
wird, aus welchem Grund, wenn es verpflichte
ist, eine Verpflichtung zu Q von a aufzugeben, wenn es ein
Verpflichtung zu P von etwas,
as wir ausgedrückt haben, anerkennt  Wir drücken
ausdrücklich durch die Verwendung des normativen Vokabulars von Tag zu Tag aus
Die kanonische
Form einer responsiven Antwort ist, weil es
unmöglich ist, beide
Eigenschaften von P und Q aufzuweisen, nämlich etwas
, das explizit durch die Verwendung eines
dicken modalen Vokabulars ausgedrückt werden
kann. Die Bedingung für echtes Wissen ist bei diesem
Modell in dem Sinne erfüllt, dass es nicht
semantisch ist  Das Modell schließt aus, dass die
epistemische Verpflichtung zur Isomorphie
der subjektiven Normen der Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz und der objektiven modalen
Tatsachen, die in der semantischen
Beziehung zwischen ihnen impliziert ist,
zumindest lokal vorübergehend objektiv gelten sollte,
und das Modell gibt auch
der Möglichkeit des Irrtums einen Sinn  denn der
folgende Inhalt konstruiert die
Repräsentationsbeziehung in normativen
Begriffen, indem er Verpflichtungen
gemäß einer bestimmten Reihe von
konzeptionellen Normen manipuliert, die deontische
Beziehungen von Unvereinbarkeit und
Konsequenz sind  Weg
sowie zu den empirisch bestimmten Tatsachen auf der Grundebene,
die sie als so artikulieren
, wie man sie annimmt, und das
Modell sagt auch, was der Fall sein muss,
damit diese Isomorphie-Relation tatsächlich nicht
zutrifft, dann hat man die
Tatsachen vielleicht falsch verstanden, einschließlich  Die Tatsachen
darüber, welche Konzepte die
objektive Welt gut artikulieren Ich habe mir in diesem Vortrag zum
Ziel gesetzt, sechs Dinge zu tun, um
die genaue Bandbreite
erkenntnistheoretischer Theorien,
die von Descartes und Kant verkörpert werden und
in den Zielbereich von Hegels
Kritik fallen, klar abzugrenzen  der
Einwand, den er gegen
Theorien dieser Art in einer Weise erhebt, die
seine Argumentation nicht offensichtlich verfehlt, um
Hegels Angemessenheitskriterien
für eine Theorie zu formulieren
, die dem implizit
positiv ins Spiel gebrachten Einwand nicht unterliegen würde
die nicht-psychologische Konzeption des Konzeptuellen herausarbeiten,
die das
Rückgrat von Hegels Antwort bilden wird
, obwohl diese Konzeption n ist  Ich werde nicht
offiziell in der
Einleitung selbst eingeführt, sondern muss auf
die Eröffnungskapitel des
Bewusstseinsabschnitts warten, um die
allgemeinen Umrisse eines erkenntnistheoretischen
und semantischen Ansatzes zu skizzieren, der auf dieser
Konzeption des Begrifflichen basiert, und
schließlich angibt, wie ein solcher Ansatz
die Kriterien von erfüllen könnte  Angemessenheit
für eine Theorie, die nicht der Hagel-
Unterwerfung unterliegt In der nächsten Vorlesung schaue ich mir
die Anzahl der Repräsentationen genauer an,
die ich
Hegel aus den Elementen konstruiere, die
durch diese Diskussion ins Spiel gebracht wurden. Danke,
also haben wir bitte ein bisschen Zeit für die Diskussion